i'm the cool dad that's that's my thing
[Music]
be really bad
[Music]
claire and i look forward to some
naughty role playing sexually
adventurous cuckolder juliana and clive
bixby speaker salesman by day spy by
night love her also by night and
sometimes during the day
so
you're up for a little adventure
never did catch what you do
didn't you surprising i know i'm usually
pretty good at catching things from
women in bars
well clive i am just a bored housewife
with a dark side
and an hour to kill
is that what i think it is it's not a
gift card
or maybe it is
i'll be upstairs clive
don't take too long
i never do
[Music]
juliana
clive where are you
you have to come find me
oh
hello
um
i give up where are you i'm right here
on the bed
phil what room are you in who's this
fish seriously what room are you in i'm
in
702 i'm in 226. what
well
whose room is this then
yeah
there's been a tiny mistake
[Music]
pretty and smart
should i say
pretty smart
[Music]
clive bixby what a sexy surprise quick
question
did it hurt when you fell from heaven
because you so
i'm gonna come in again
i'd like admission to your student body
oh my goodness i am so sorry i thought
you were my wife what's going on he
grabbed me and said i thought she was my
wife my wife works out a lot dad
how'd he grab you he squeezed my butt
he what i thought it was you
believe me sir i'm a respected realtor
this is an innocent mistake honey turn
around and show him your butt it's it's
uncanny
oh by the way if you ever speak
disrespectfully again about my wife i'll
kill you
sorry that sounded like a joke i will
actually kill you
anyhoo
there are two things i know with dead
certainty
how to shoulder roll out of a human
pyramid and the bike arts of the
butler's escape i mean phil is usually
just so but then he was just like so
and then he got even more
there's nothing i can do i can't go for
that no can do cameron here bought an
eggshell dryer not white not oatmeal not
swiss coffee not baby powder not bone
eggshell look rob is it that's
interesting here's how this is going
down
we don't leave without that eggshell
dryer not swan feather not chester pig
white i think we've covered the colors
i sell houses to people every day who
ask me where they should buy their dryer
i don't think you want me giving them
any
static
i may have one in the back
but it takes two guys to load the truck
and it's just me today is it
it was right about then that a question
started nagging at me
[Music]
is phil sexy
first we have a date with a
romance a threesome if you will what did
you do to your face just a little color
to make my eyes pop
like yours are now you're covering this
may have been my fault i think i was
being too sexy
yeah i don't think that's an issue you
sure about that my god i'm beautiful
there she is the old library had some
late nights in there
some of them may even spend studying
don't tell your mom
[Applause]
oh
oh for god thanks phil just swear like
an adult no
part of me always knew this is how i was
gonna go out in a wine fire surrounded
by raccoons wait
[Music]
oh my goodness oh yes
what what is this
[Music]
you shut your mouth oh yeah
and since the neighbors can't take a
hand
oh that was amazing
my dear
nothing but the best for you
on our anniversary
now
where were we
may i have this dance yes
oh
i am the luckiest girl in the world
did you get me a mop
[Music]
dance until your feet hurt
sing until your lungs hurt act
until your william heard
the minute i stopped caring what other
people thought and started doing what i
wanted to do is the minute
i finally fell free
no son of mine's going to high school
without at least knowing how to do a
proper box step
trust me dancers always get the girls
remember the great kevin bacon from
footloose more like foot loser careful
happy melon birth of bursary
should there be another adult present no
but there should be a kid present that
kid is you
you've got your whole life to roll your
eyes today isn't just about building a
duck village
it's about building your smile don't
bite it
there it is
[Music]
buddy
you're gonna make your own choices
and whatever you decide i'll always
support you you're not just saying all
this because you're stuck right nothing
you decide
will ever disappoint me
thanks dad
relax your arms
roll your shoulders forward bend down
your head
exhale and then arch
oh
it sort of worked
[Music]
[Music]
my